le jingle
c'est bien on voit qu'elle a bossé bien
alors c'est une interview première fois
un premier choc
la perte d'un de quelqu'un de la famille
c'était là une la grand mère de mon père
et c'est là que j'ai vu mon père pour la
première fois pleurer c'est l'un des
premiers amours blancs souvenez quand
même bref si j'avais je crois trois ou
quatre ans mais rien n'est moins sûr à
la haye la serbie sous le préau et ses
services très très gentil est-ce que
l'histoire de votre ami qui vous a fait
du mal ce n'était pas l'histoire des
grandes filles les autres fouilles mais
c'est un amour malsain c'est un amour
qui fait souffrir c'est un amour dans
lequel on s'enferme justement c'est vous
alors que vous faites aussi moche
oui et non c'est inconscient vous allez
me souvenir verbund présent c'est
quelque chose qui est très très fréquent
on se plaît à aimer quelqu'un qui vous
fait souffrir que ce soit en amour en
alsace voilà
c'est ça ouais ouais maternelle
justement ce premier amour prochaine
tuerie
ou alors comme ça voilà les également
que ces barques et la langue
c'était pitoyable de voir tous ces gens
nous reste que j'avais entre 12 et 13
ans je sais plus et je me souviens non
mais je mate ou bien je me souviens
j'étais il y avait une petite place un
arrêt de bus et je dis au revoir à la
fin c'était mon premier baiser avec sa
langue je me suis entendu je gardais mes
copines mais j'ai fais vraiment les
premiers falloir pousser chez marc est
repoussé à j'avais jeté au mois de mai
un voyage à venise
voilà le cas l'année j'avais un beau
visage mais n'ont jamais entre j'avais
j'allais vers des 16 ans donc se faire
engueuler par alonso nous c'est pas pour
l'heure à pois zi première fois toute
nue
donnez là non c'est marqué sur la place
c'est pas du tout séduit la vigne est
sécurisé mais non première je sais pas
quel âge mais avant ces premières fois
tout mon premier amour le vrai rencontre
est déjà le premier jeu cela plusieurs
devient pas très longtemps
pendant le premier mois à mons et ya pas
très longtemps ça fait un an et demi
l'été il y en s'excusant et éboué
premier rupture là pas de rupture pas si
c'est première vraie rupture dont je me
souviens bien qu'ils m'aient qui m'a
mangé un peu de mal à digérer
je crois que je venais d'avoir 14 ans
est ce qu'il y aurait rupture quand il y
a pas d'amour du tout mais y'a de la
manche ont envie commune comme il ya
l'armée s'est défait de l'amour c'est
l'amour des dos et un truc on craque sur
quelqu'un on reste avec lui deux mois et
et puis voilà et puis on se rend compte
avec le temps que c'est pas dit c'est
pas de l'amour mais que la rupture est
toujours en souffrance à ce moment là de
leur bourg soit en plus de ça on voit
que nous entamons le monde sap était la
copine moi finalement tu vois pas à le
vrai amour vous certainement mais sandro
voilà alors c'est quoi première cuite
c'est ça au monde appelle le bernois
c'était tellement
le clézio
on est conscient pour traîner par les
amènera une émission barre des 6 grandes
vacances à cholet mouchoirs voilà avec
mes parents et j'étais parti avec une
amie et on a rencontré de jeunes
parisiens vont vous trouvez plutôt sympa
et tout qui aimerait jouer tennis et
puis oui ce soir on fait la fête on
ramène des bouteilles et qui la bière et
je ne sais quoi et puis vint je suis
bien ramasser voilà ce en voilà comment
je pense qu'ils évoluent à vos parents
regardent
non mais il savait ce que je me suis
fait un peu chantée par maman sang la
haine et inscriptions par ta maman qui
t'appelle spécial sûr c'est que plus on
importe quoi le faire au match